hi Samuel leaves here do you have a
spouse a partner or a family member who
is not backing you and supporting you in
your property investment journey you
have people that are holding you back
and not believing in you if you do this
video is for you so stay tuned when I
started out in my property investment
journey I was just a teenager and I had
a lot of people supporting me I had a
lot of people backing me and of course I
have also had people who were saying
that's a silly decision when are you
gonna get a proper job both friends and
in my family and I think this sounds
gonna be the case for you you're gonna
have a real mixture of people and it's
really important to focus on the good in
your life because what you focus on
expands so I'm going to address two
things right here two potential problems
one is just that the world seems to be
against you your friends your family
members and everyone's telling you this
is not possible property investing is
risky that's one problem the other
problem is that you are married to
somebody you have a husband or a wife or
a spouse who's being very cynical and
holding you back that's a whole
different story because you guys share
money and they're telling you that you
cannot or should not get into property
and they're two totally different things
now my advice to you would be if you're
dealing with the first problem of
everyone saying that it's hard
everyone's telling me not so everybody
really or are you just focusing on those
people and just to find your own lack of
activity because of other people now if
you focus on the three or four people
that are saying oh I think that's risky
instead of the two or three four five
ten people that are saying go for it
then that's going to expand in your
brain and hold you back so focus on
focus on the good and that will expand
also surround yourself with different
friends surround yourself with positive
people surround yourself with success
buddies so that that would be my advice
if you just got generally people in your
family or your friends holding you back
however if you've got your husband or
wife your spouse your life partner
holding you back that is different
because you share money and if you're if
you've got say a hundred thousand pound
equity in your house and you
saying I'd love to refinance and buy a
few houses if you hate GMOs to invest
invest in and your spouse says no then
what are you doing now in your mind you
might be thinking you've got two options
option one is to tell your spouse I'm
doing it anyway screw you and if you
don't like it we can split up or option
number two is you can just not invest
buckle under and live an average life
and resent your partner forever what I
would like to tell you is that I don't
think they are your only two options I
think there's an option number three
which we call winning them over winning
them over winning them over is so easy
to do and there's so many different ways
you can win them over number one would
be to send them along to one of my
property investors crash courses and
then see how unmotivated they are in
property investing let me do the work
for you or let them read my book you
know or all other sources so that's
that's that's option one of winning
leather another way you could win them
over is you could just say to them look
this is really important to me and all I
know I'd come out this work if it goes
wrong I'll take responsibility but will
you just trust me and let me do this if
you say that there's a fair chance the
help site go on then but on your head
option number three and this is probably
one of my favorites but you can do a
combination is to rather than thinking
you've got a choice you can either be a
complete property investor and put all
your money and all your time and quit
the job become a property investor or do
nothing do do a little bit dip your toe
in the water
and show them how it goes just say to
them so hey if I can just invest in some
education and I can buy one house one
house and I by doing that like we can
just bought proportion of our savings
just a small proportion or Norman Saul
let me just try and do it normally down
deal just find a compromise where you
can just you know you can you can spend
a certain amount of money or just a
certain amount of time and then show
them there is
oops and I promise you when you spend
just a little bit of money you show them
the return again or you put a little bit
of money in your going to your education
or you put some time apps triumph on
some deals and then you can show them
look I only spent two days and spent a
little bit of travel some training you
look what we've got we've just got to
nobody down deals to three houses and
we're making a grand a month then you
want to be on with them over your over
because if thank you a hundred percent
that you are not going to fail and the
property investing was actually
fantastic they want you to do it the
problem is that they don't believe it
works so just with a little bit of money
a little bit of time prove them that it
works do not say I told you so I make it
about you make it about them and say
look look what we've managed to do here
you know we put this much money we've
done this and let them think of the idea
and it won't be long before they say hmm
if you could do that with just that much
money and just that much time imagine
what would happen if we bought this much
in if you still can't win them over even
after you've done that if you've told
them look this is important to me trust
me and they're not having it and then
you've just invested a little bit of
your time or a little bit of money which
is agreed and it's working really well
and the returns are great and and
they're still not happy and you've
proved them that it works you've told
them to trust you and they still aren't
feeling air and they're just holding you
back then you've just got to make a
decision I mean personally I don't think
I would be able to be successful and be
doing half of what I'm doing in the
business if I didn't have a really
really supportive wife and it's great
but as soon as they start experiencing a
bit of financial freedom I mean right
here right now how we are just out this
is the see right here this is the ocean
and we're staying an absolutely
beautiful hotel my wife is having a
massage I mean pampered do you rethink
if your spouse was here all the while
being massaged and everything because a
result of your decisions in property
they would be still saying no it's too
risky I really don't think so thank you
so much for watching if you benefited
from that video please do share it with
your family and friends for more videos
like it you can watch right here and if
you'd like to spend two days with me at
the property investors crash course
watch this video see what happens but
whatever you do don't forget just
scribe right here and I'll see you next
time